So I guess the case that I was making last time,
at least in part,
was that
you're one of one way of conceptualizing the fundamental problem that human
beings face,
is to conceptualize it as an ongoing struggle with complexity and
complexity
emerges as a consequence of
the sort of finite boundedness of individual consciousness.
And uh,
it incredible excess of the unbounded every way are everywhere else even
including underneath that consciousness.
Because of course your individual consciousness depends on the function or is
related to the function of things that are so complex.
You can't even understand it.
So there you are surrounded by some things that you understand in an,
in an ocean of things that you don't understand at all and including things
about yourself.
And it's not obvious at all how people solve that problem because in some sense
it's not solvable.
The fact that you don't have the cognitive resources or the conceptual resources
to understand everything that you need to understand in order to properly orient
yourself in the world.
Now obviously,
partly the way we deal with that is that we cooperate with other people and so
that radically multiplies our resources and credibly multiplies our resources.
So,
and it's all,
it's something to consider always when,
so much of the political dialog that surrounds us now consists of a critique of,
of cooperative societies and uh,
an analysis of their oppressive nature.
Of course that's true because any cooperative system,
it specifies a certain endpoint and produces a value hierarchy of some sort.
Also simultaneously forces things into that value system.
And then rank orders,
people according to the value structure and so there's an oppressive element to
it,
but compared to being naked in chaos,
generally it's better now.
It doesn't always have to be because it can get murderous.
But generally speaking,
well look,
we're social animals.
It doesn't matter.
Our evolutionary pathway has already taken us here and so we're individuals,
but we're unbelievably social and so that's that.
So as far as I can tell,
we'd have to be completely different creatures not to fall,
not to take advantage of and fall prey to the problems with social being.
Alright.
So
I think the way that the problem of complexity has been solved,
and this is the best argument I know of for the truth of the Darwinian notion of
evolution now,
I don't think that our models of evolution are complete by any stretch of the
imagination.
All right?
I know they're not partly because of recent work done in epigenetics,
which suggests that you can acquire,
you can inherit acquired traits.
Right?
And when I went to university,
when I started going to university in the 19 eighties,
that was heresy really.
Like,
no,
you cannot inherit acquired traits,
but actually you can inherit acquired traits.
That's the field of epigenetic studies.
That and that.
That's a radical shift in perspective because we also don't know exactly what
that means across any length of time.
And when you're thinking about evolutionary lengths of time,
you're thinking about three and a half billion years because that's the span of
time over which life evolved.
And so even things that don't have a overwhelmingly market potency for one
generation can be unbelievably powerful across time.
And then there's also the issue of sexual sexual selection because you know,
you'll hear darwinist continually described the world and the evolutionary world
as a place of randomness and that's not true and I don't know why they make that
statement.
The mutations are random or quasi random because we don't understand mutations
that well yet either.
And most mutations are deadly,
right?
Most mutations are deadly.
There's a set of them that are harmful but not deadly.
And then there's a tiny,
tiny proportion that could in principle produced some benefit to the next
generation assuming environmental environmental shift,
say in the direction of the mutation.
So.
And that's,
there's a randomness element to that.
We know that,
I mean,
part of the reason that you mutate or your cells mutate your DNA mutates is
because of background levels of radioactivity.
And a lot of that's a consequence of solar activity,
right?
So cosmic rays come zipping through the atmosphere and they nail your DNA and
produce minor alterations and that's a mutation.
And if you crank up the background radiation rate,
like say around Chernobyl,
then the mutation rate rises.
And there's definitely a random element to that and it's necessary for there to
be a random element because as far as I can tell,
the only way you can beat a random environment is by producing random changes.
Right?
So you know the idea,
basically the,
the environment isn't some static place that's selecting for higher and higher
levels of fitness or not in any,
not in any.
It's certainly not doing that in any static way.
And so it's shifting around randomly and then you know,
you have a structure that's been your species has a structure that's a
consequence of this immense evolutionary journey and it's moderating itself
randomly within certain parameters.
The parameters being that most mutations will kill you,
like alterations in your fundamental form generally tend to kill you.
So they're incremental and so the mutations are random and they match.
Hopefully they ratchet the randomness in the environmental shift and so you can
more or less up that way,
but then there's additional complicating factors and they're not trivial.
And one of them is whatever epigenetics does.
We don't know anything about that yet.
But the second one is sexual selection.
And sexual selection is no joke.
It could be the primary thing is certainly one of the primary things that's
driven human evolution and I think you can say that
you think about the environment.
Again,
let's think about the environment.
So you have a dominance hierarchy and that's really old structure.
The dominance hierarchy is 300 million years old because it emerged pretty much
whenever there was.
Whenever there was a nervous system,
emergent nervous system and whatever.
Animals had to occupy the same territory.
They automatically organized themselves into something approximating a dominance
hierarchy.
So it's a very,
very,
very old structure.
It's older than trees.
It's older than flowers,
it's old.
And as far as real goes from a Darwinian sense,
permanent is real.
And so when you,
you can say,
well,
you know,
arboreal ancestors adapted themselves to trees and so the tree was a long around
long enough to be a feature of the environment.
But the dominance hierarchy has been around a lot longer than trees.
And you can think of the dominance hierarchy both as an adaptation to the
environment,
because you'd kind of think about the dominant Turkey has a cultural construct,
but if a cultural construct lasts long enough that it becomes part of the
environment and so the dominant Turkey's part of the environment and what seems
to happen roughly speaking,
and this is an oversimplification but we'll go with it,
is that males have a dominance hierarchy and there's a relatively small number
of males that are relatively successful and those successful males have
preferential access to female reproductive capacity either because the females
actively choose the the more dominant males,
which is very,
very common or because the more dominant males chase all the less dominant males
away so that even if the females don't exercise choice,
which they often do,
then the only males left around that can serve as reasonable.
Mating partners are the more powerful ones.
And so you think you got to really radical determiners of evolution as a
consequence of that one.
Is that each.
I'm not talking about female dominance hierarchies at the moment,
but I can talk about that,
but that's why this is oversimplification,
but what happens is that the males obviously are selected for their ability to
move up dominance hierarchies obviously because the ones that are at the top of
the dominance hierarchy reproduce preferentially and so that means the male
dominance hierarchy becomes a method of selection,
but then allied with that is the female proclivity for choice on whatever
dimension the dominance hierarchy happens to be arranged and so then female
sexual selection also becomes a radical nonrandom selector of,
of,
of what,
what genetic material is going to move into the next generation.
And so I,
I failed to see how any of that can be separated from the emergence of complex
nervous systems and mind over the course of evolution because people are.
Creatures aren't making random choices.
They're not random at all.
So we even know such things like imagine a peacock's tail,
you know,
it's covered with ice,
which is quite interesting because eyes of course attract attention and lots of
animals have evolved.
I liked markets like moss.
There's moss that when they unfold their wings,
they have two big eyes on the back of them and that's to keep birds from eating
them right?
Because the birds don't like being stared at,
so they stay away from the moths.
But so a peacock's tail,
there's nothing but eyes and so it's very attractive and it shimmers and there's
something about it that's beautiful,
which is quite interesting to.
The females have obviously been selecting the male peacock peacocks for beauty.
They have this insane tail while so they,
evolutionary biologists have thought,
well,
what possible utility could that tail be?
Is it just maybe the females got fixated on tail,
so to speak,
and you know,
you've got a Baldwin infect loop going there and the male peacocks just got
bigger and bigger tales and it's just like an evolutionary dead end.
It's,
you know,
it's a positive feedback system that's gone out of control,
but they have done things that like look at the cemetery and,
and,
and breadth say,
or the symmetry and size and overall quality of the male peacock's tail as a
marker for physical health.
So reduce parasite load for example.
And it does turn out that the healthier male peacocks have better tail display.
And so the way what the females seem to be doing is using some marker or some
set of markers as a proxy indicator for,
for,
for health.
And I think I think you could say with,
with reasonable,
you could say reasonable that reasonably that female human beings do the same
thing to male human beings.
And there's some of that vice versa too.
Like we evaluate each other,
for example,
for symmetry,
which is one of the elements of beauty because healthier people tend to be more
symmetrical and lots of animals use symmetry.
Butterflies,
butterflies won't mate with another butterfly if it deviates from cemetery by
the tiniest amounts you can imagine.
So symmetry is a marker.
And there's other markers like shoulder width to waist width is one,
and waist to hip width is another.
That's usually what mail is.
Use that to evaluate females in part.
So there's lots of markers of health.
But it also looks to me like the data worldwide seems to indicate that women.
So imagine that women May to cross dominance,
hierarchies end up socioeconomically speaking,
and on average across cultures,
women go for men who were about four to five years older,
you know,
it varies in the Scandinavian countries,
that's shrunk a little bit,
but not that much.
And in other cultures it's bigger.
I would say that depends to some degree on difficulty of establishing economic
independence,
right?
Because in richer countries it's easier to have enough economic independence if
you're a male to be,
to be a useful participant in the process of having children.
Um,
but it doesn't matter.
Cross culturally,
it's still across the nop were manmade across and down.
They don't care much about socioeconomic status.
Doesn't seem to be part of their selection method.
Um,
generally speaking.